es posible que reciba intubación
endotraqueal y ventilación mecánica si
se encuentra en una situación de
emergencia que involucre problemas
respiratorios severos o si se encuentra
bajo anestesia general durante un
procedimiento quirúrgico cuando respira
el aire ingresa a sus pulmones cuando un
músculo llamado diafragma junto con
otros músculos cercanos se contraen y
hacen que la cavidad torácica se expanda
el aire exhalado cuando estos músculos
se relajan y el tejido pulmonar regresa
lentamente a su tamaño original esto se
llama respiración durante la respiración
el oxígeno del aire pasa a través de su
nariz o boca hacia su faringe o garganta
luego ingresa a su tráquea o tubo aéreo
su tráquea se divide para formar los
bronquios derechos e izquierdos
principales los cuales ingresan a sus
pulmones dentro de sus pulmones los
bronquios principales se dividen
reiteradamente y finalmente se
convierten en pequeños tubos llamados
bronquiolos en los extremos de los
bronquios se encuentran pequeños sacos
aire llamados alveolos el oxígeno en sus
alveolos es absorbido dentro de pequeños
vasos sanguíneos cercanos llamados vasos
capilares al mismo tiempo el dióxido de
carbono un gas en su sangre que debe ser
eliminado ingresa a los alveolos y sale
a través de las vías respiratorias este
proceso se llama intercambio de gases si
tiene problemas respiratorios severos
los niveles de oxígeno en su sangre
pueden descender demasiado o los niveles
de dióxido de carbono pueden elevarse
demasiado cualquiera de estas
condiciones puede dañar sus órganos
vitales incluyendo su corazón y cerebro
algunas condiciones que pueden provocar
problemas respiratorios severos incluyen
ahogamiento una obstrucción en la
tráquea tal como un objeto extraño o
tumor enfermedades pulmonares
obstructivas tales como asma bronquitis
crónica y enfisema enfermedades tales
como neumonía y síndrome de dificultad
respiratoria aguda o sdr a debilidad
severa de los músculos que controlan la
respiración y daño a los huesos y
tejidos del pecho
bajo estas circunstancias es posible que
necesite oxígeno adicional o ayuda para
respirar a través de la ventilación
mecánica la ventilación mecánica también
se usa durante procedimientos
quirúrgicos para administrar anestésicos
evitar la aspiración de contenidos del
estómago hacia los pulmones y controlar
de cerca los niveles de oxígeno y
dióxido de carbono en la sangre durante
la cirugía antes de intubarlo y
ventilarlo para un procedimiento
quirúrgico se le colocará una vía
intravenosa
y ve
y su médico le administrará medicamentos
a través de su pib para que se duerma a
medida que el medicamento hace efecto el
médico colocará una máscara de oxígeno
sobre su nariz y boca y le pedirá que
respire profundo asegurándose de que
usted contará con una reserva de oxígeno
en su cuerpo antes del procedimiento el
primer paso en la ventilación mecánica
se llama intubación endotraqueal
una vez dormido su médico utilizará un
instrumento llamado laringoscopio para
realizar la intubación un laringoscopio
que está compuesto por un mango una luz
y una hoja sin filo ayuda a guiar el
tubo endotraqueal a su posición adecuada
su médico inclinará su cabeza hacia
atrás ligeramente e insertará el
laringoscopio a través de su boca hacia
su garganta teniendo especial cuidado de
no tocar sus dientes utilizando la hoja
su médico levantará con cuidado la
epiglotis que es un colgajo de tejido
que protege su laringe
luego para ingresar la punta del tubo
endotraqueal en la tráquea
una vez que el tubo endotraqueal esté en
la tráquea su médico inflar a un globo
pequeño alrededor del tubo para
asegurarse de que se ajuste bien en su
lugar su médico retirará el
laringoscopio y unirá con cinta adhesiva
el tubo a la esquina de su boca para
evitar que se salga de su posición
su médico revisará si el tubo está
colocado correctamente en la parte baja
de la tráquea al inflar sus pulmones con
una bolsa especial y al escuchar sus
sonidos respiratorios en ambos lados de
su pecho si el extremo del tubo está muy
abajo ambos pulmones no recibirán la
misma cantidad de aire en algunos casos
se toma una radiografía inmediatamente
después de la incubación para confirmar
la ubicación del tubo una vez que el
tubo endotraqueal esté en la posición
adecuada su médico lo conectará al
ventilador mecánico una bomba
especialmente diseñada que ayuda a la
respiración al suministrar aire bien
oxigenado a los pulmones y permitiendo
que el dióxido de carbono salga de los
pulmones los niveles de oxígeno y
dióxido de carbono se controlarán
cerca para confirmar que el ventilador
está funcionando una vez que termine su
procedimiento quirúrgico su médico no
retirará el tubo endotraqueal hasta que
usted sea capaz de respirar por sí mismo
con seguridad esto se determinará al
medir cuán seguido respira y cuánto aire
inhala y exhala en cada respiración